hey guys back a Roseanne's kitchen table
with kara and i wanted to talk about
tying that happened to me this week and
again my science chick is with me so
hopefully you can break this down I was
sick this week I was sneezing I was
coughing sore throat etc etc I'm so glad
to be sitting this color yes I think I
think we're in the clear what is that
there's got to be a scientific term for
that when when I'm right on the other
side of the sickness well yeah you can't
catch it yeah you're no longer
communicable no longer contagious
communicable any of the movies that were
you know okay so I was sick there was
something going around la cuz everyone
that I know has been getting sick for
the last like three weeks my boyfriend
went to the doctor the doctor said
something was going around and it would
had been started right before January
anyway you can hear it a little bit of
my voice now but I'm basically better
but so the doctor gave me some medicine
like some cough stuff and some you know
decongestant kind of stuff and it like
kind of worked kind of didn't work I
couldn't really tell but then David made
chicken soup like seriously homemade
stock chicken soup spiced the hell out
of it cayenne everything and within 10
minutes of eating it completely clear I
could breathe i could smell i felt much
better my like the pressure was gone all
that so i think you can see what i'm
going with science lady medicine versus
just home remedies and homeopathic stuff
because this to me was I'm not big on
all the medicine in general I try not to
take it unless I have to you know if you
want to anti-inflammatory there's other
ways to marrek or whatever there's other
ways than taking medicine and I of
course medicine works at times and you
need to take it for certain things and
food can't resolve everything but this
was an example of sort of to me at least
doing something that works for you and
and that sometimes that's the best way
to do it i know i agree with you i think
that i think it's about sometimes having
these kinds of conversations really do
come down to terminology and
unfortunately you kind of have to get
that stuff out of the way so we're
talking about medicine right but
medicine chicken soup is medicine if
you're specifically saying the
difference between a pharmaceutical drug
that is for sale
a pharmacy counter or is for sale at you
know CBS right versus something that you
can produce at home sure those are
different conversations but when we talk
about for example medicine pretty much
anything that you take in your body that
has a medicinal medicinal effect aka
makes you feel better we could probably
call medicine if we use the word drug
alcohol is a drug you know marijuana is
a drug but also so is tylenol these are
all drugs so we've got a marijuana did
not help the cough I tried no that's
probably not a good idea but I find
marijuana good for upset tum tums yeah
not so much good for foggy head not good
for value no no I found it gives you a
headache you I should have called them
better exactly it probably not good to
smoke it for the yeah yeah um chicken
soup amazing yeah i recommend hot pot my
favorite sichuan dish from china ah it's
just in very spicy sounds very good yes
amazing brought there and so the idea
here that home remedies are something
that we should shy away from because we
are scientific thinkers i think is
totally bogus because there's science
behind the food right i mean there's
reasons but the food was evidence so
soon but the issue here is are we
talking about a treatment for an
infection or a treatment for some sort
of disease process or are we talking
about things that make us feel better
and so the truth is the chicken soup
made you feel better because it cleared
up your nasal passages and you could
breathe again which is huge when you
have a cold that's huge the cold virus I
sincerely doubt it did anything to the
cold virus that was residing inside of
your body right your immune system was
fighting off the cold virus and the
reason when you have a cold usually that
your doctor prescribes you a
decongestant and and an antihistamine or
something to clear up the drainage is
because if you continue to have drainage
down your sinuses into your throat while
you have a cold it can often advanced
into some sort of a throat infection or
a lung infection right and that can be
dangerous so you want to dry all that
stuff up so that you don't get you know
a bacterial infection as a secondary
infection from your so you're saying
chicken suits not going to do all that
note it's gonna help with this for
example right and this is where if we
take this to an extreme example yeah
this is where I start to have a hard
time we
um conversations about things like
naturopathy homeopathy uh holistic
medicine all those terms means something
different so so let's be clear about
that yeah if you are diagnosed for
example with cancer if you are diagnosed
with diabetes there are certain disease
states in the body that biologists can
point to they know what's happening
there and if you want to have any real
chance of beating it you will look at
evidence-based medicine which means that
there have been years and years and
years of scientist trying to tackle this
problem and they've been working very
hard to develop different treatments
that we know work chemotherapy works
chemotherapy is horrible for you I don't
get me wrong it's basically killing you
right there so that's the nice thing is
we're getting to understand more about
molecular markers in cancer so for
example let's say you have breast cancer
which is a very common type of cancer
there may be some sort of estrogen
marker in that breast cancer that's only
in those cells that's that's good news
because that means that then you can
target that marker when you treat it and
you don't have to kill healthy tissue
around it unfortunately not all cancer
works that way but we know that
chemotherapy works and we know that
radiation chemotherapy whatever your
oncologist is recommending to you is
historically and evidence-based the best
way to go about treating it taking shark
cartilage and rhino horn and drinking
green tea is not going to cure your
cancer it's not now that doesn't mean
that your cancer is going to go away
completely if you also take these other
steps that are evidence-based to work it
just means that you're going to have a
significantly better chance it bothers
me when people try to say that like
somehow the medical industrial complex
is for example holding out on legitimate
treatments that you can find right in
your home that you can buy if shark
cartilage cured cancer trust me somebody
would have patented start killing more
shark exactly and that would be
available as a legitimate treatment it's
not you know they always say what do we
call alternative medicine that works
medicine it's not alternative anymore
that's that's the important thing to
think about chicken soup is not an
alternative medicine chicken soup is
something that very much can help you
when you feel ill because it makes you
feel better yeah
do you think it's weird how people sort
of think that the Eastern Western
versions of Medicine are so in conflict
with each other because actually the
cancer example when you were saying that
it makes me think like so you can go and
do the chemo and then actually there are
plenty of people that then smoke weed or
take edibles after whatever to deal with
the nausea to deal with the pain they
then they eat more so actually these are
two things that can be used together
yeah and they'll do mindfulness
meditation which can really improve
treatment strategies there's all sorts
of amazing treatments out there that are
non-medicinal that that make you feel
better and ultimately do contribute to
your ability to to physically get better
to whether it's for your immune system
to be boosted enough to fight off
infection or whether it's to be rested
enough for the medicine to be able to
work and that's something that's
important to sleep eating getting
exercise these aren't things that a pill
can help you with they're things that
you physically have to do but they
probably have almost as much of an
effect depending on what you're going
through yeah in improving your prognosis
for getting better so you know I think
the issue that I take with as a
skeptical activist and as somebody who
is involved in the skeptic community our
issue is with charlatans it's it's with
snake oil salesmen it's with people who
actively try to push products they don't
have any evidence to prove their
efficacy and literally take advantage of
people when they're in those final
throes when they're the most desperate
and that to me is just it's highly
immoral and it's something that we
should be stopping using the tools that
science is given up right so just to be
clear to sort of wrap this all up
there's a huge distinction there it's
not you're not against the other stuff
as a science-based person you're not
against the other stuff that could help
the meditation it's the people that are
pushing it as a substitute for what is
empirically I may be generously proven
yes I'm against not doing the
evidence-based medicine in in favor of
doing something alternative that has no
evidence to support its efficacy you do
what you know science has shown time and
time again to have give you the best
success and the other things that you do
to make you feel better to make you for
your spiritual person if you're a
religious person too
make you feel more rounded better
equipped to fight this disease great and
also again this is all personal this is
all a very personal decision people make
you know and and we could have a whole
other conversation about the power of
positive thinking and the dress I have
that idea of fighting cancer not
succumbing to cancer like these are all
different conversations that we can have
but I I would never tell anybody what to
do with their own body what I will tell
you is that if you are a religious
person who believes in faith healing and
you don't give your kid a vaccination or
you don't take your kid to the doctor
when they're sick and your kid dies
because of that you are a criminal and
you are criminally negligent because you
were choosing alternative treatments
over traditional ones that science has
shown us work I was going to try to end
this on a positive note we were almost
there well you know but you all right so
yeah Western Eastern what do you do when
you're sick do you do you believe in all
the homeopathic stuff do you believe in
the science you do a little blend of
both which is what I try to do help me
off with these [ __ ] homeopathy is
[ __ ] let us know rather than other
Eastern treatments comments right Evelyn